Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous présente
au bonheur des livres
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'émission
littéraire de Public Sénat au bonheur
des livres qu'est-ce qu'un bon film
disait Orson Wells c'est un film qui
mérite qu'on paye son ticket son
restaurant et son baby-sitting enfin un
bon film c'est aussi un film qui a de
bons scénaristes de bons réalisateurs ou
réalisatrices de bonnes équipes
techniques et puis de bons acteurs de
bonnes actrices on va notamment parler
d'elle de dans cette émission spéciale
consacrée au cinéma au moment où se
déroule le Festival de Cannes et pour
parler de ça nous avons invité Frédéric
mitterrandelli bonsoir monsieur le
ministre
c'est fini ah mais c'est comme ça c'est
ta vie que voulez-vous
est-ce qu'il est besoin de vous
présenter vous avez été acteur
exploitant de salles de cinéma vous êtes
auteur vous êtes réalisateur vous avez
été un animateur
bien connu pas du tout on s'y perd pas
parce que votre personnalité demeure des
missions
radiophoniques ou télévision consacré au
cinéma au style célèbre
au livre aussi vous avez été ministre de
la Culture et vous êtes un académicien
assez peu académique je dois le dire et
vous publiez aux éditions XO Brad un
livre que vous consacrez à Brad Pitt
donc vous dites qu'il est un concentré
d'énergie sexuelle à au voltage on va
revenir à vous et nous avons également
invité Patrick Rogers vous êtes
romancier essayiste critique vous avez
une soixantaine de livres à votre actif
et vous publiez chez Grasset nouvelle
vague
un objet littéraire non identifié qui
est un roman un récit un essai et tout
ça et quelque chose d'autre encore mais
qui présente fait un tableau assez
vivant et très détaillé de la nouvelle
vague et de ses protagonistes alors on
va commencer par ça rappelez-nous s'il
vous plaît ce que c'était que la
Nouvelle Vague ils viennent des Cahiers
du cinéma c'est à dire au fond je
considère que il faut pas faire de
cinéma pour faire du cinéma il faut
penser le cinéma il faut le voir ils
vont tout le temps à la Cinémathèque qui
décrivent ils critiquent réfléchissent
et deviennent cinéastes sans avoir fait
du cinéma sans passer par les côtes
habituelles et c'est une bouffée d'air
et de modernité d'invention de jouvence
de liberté absolument magnifique mais
entre eux moi je suis pas entre godards
et Truffaut entre le vous dites
d'ailleurs l'un et le cinéaste du samedi
soir donc du goût du public et l'autre
du lundi après-midi des cinéphiles c'est
ça donc ils sont réunis par l'envie de
faire exploser le cinéma de qualité
française qui est précédé mais entre
bien des choses et séparent oui bah moi
vous savez c'est vraiment une des choses
qui m'a fasciné c'est que le cinéma
c'est un art de la création moi ce qui
m'a impressionné c'est la création tous
ces cinéastes font un cinéma différent
et la première chose que j'ai fait
puisque mon livre n'est pas du tout un
essai sur la Nouvelle Vague il y en a
beaucoup c'est écrit un roman sur la
Nouvelle Vague au fond le roman de la
Nouvelle Vague inventé ce roman qui est
au fond une fiction avec des modes de
création différents pour chacun la
première chose que j'ai faite c'est
faire éclater les codes très stricts
qu'ils avaient en y mettant par exemple
Agnès Varda Louis mal qui ne faisait pas
vraiment partie de la nouvelle vague
mais qui a précédé ou qui conjoint dans
le temps puis ajouter par exemple Claude
merveilleux et Cinéas majeur et puis
évidemment à la rennais et en fait c'est
tout d'une cosmogonie qui se met en
place vous faites des portraits vous
faites vous raconter vous rentrez dans
des si vous avez des manies du détail
qui sont très amusants d'ailleurs vous
faites des listes tout ça est très
amusant ça allait rentrer bien alors il
y a un en effet vous l'avez dit il faut
émerger alors que ils critiquaient le
cinéma qui les apprécientés les du
Vivier
la noix de la noix autant la RAT mais ce
cinéma là avait manifié les acteurs je
pense à Gérard Philipe eux aussi
pourtant vont faire naître toute une
nouvelle génération d'acteurs
Belmondo les hauts briali dans un autre
genre Michael lonsdal donc ils ont aussi
mis les acteurs au centre de leur oui je
crois que mon livre est un texte
essentiellement d'admiration du cinéma
français et un hommage aux acteurs vous
avez des acteurs inouï comme Michel
Piccoli par exemple Michel Piccoli joue
dans les créatures d'Alès Varda le
troisième film Daniel varia qui n'est
pas connu enfin il joue aussi chez
Claude sautais il joue dans Le Mépris de
Godard et puis il joue chez rivet
et c'est pas le même piccolier
évidemment donc évidemment
ces acteurs là font ce cinéma et ils
sont dans la mythologie c'est à dire que
vous ne pouvez jamais voir un acteur
sans être traversé par tous les rôles
qu'il a joué et maintenant la Nouvelle
Vague est terminée avec la disparition
de Godard elle est vraiment terminée
mais le cinéma reste vivant à travers
les acteurs qui jouent tous les rôles
merveilleux les acteurs est-ce que je me
trompe mais le l'idée nouvelle vague ça
a été inventé par Françoise Giroud oui
dans l'Express elle a inventé la
terminologie c'est important ça veut
dire c'est les années Express aussi
c'est la fin de la 4e c'est Françoise
Giroud c'est de toute une nouvelle
génération de gens qui réfléchissent et
je ne sais plus lequel de ces cinéastes
à dire au bout d'un moment la Nouvelle
Vague s'épuise mais la mer est toujours
là mais mais alors vous parlez des
acteurs les actrices parce que on y
reviendra tout à l'heure avec Frédéric
Mitterrand mais les le la Nouvelle Vague
fêter de les actrices très célèbres de
jouer sur Delphine série
Ana Karina
Stefano Dron et oui pourtant ce ne sont
pas du tout des stars c'est pas Brigitte
Bardot il essaie du catégorie d'actrices
très particulière
ils inventent des nouveaux types c'est à
dire des femmes de tous les jours des
femmes comme on envoie dans la rue on
tourne dans la rue avec des caméras qui
font beaucoup de bruit il faut savoir
que par exemple la bout de souffle a été
tourné en son direct mais finalement peu
synchroniser comme d'ailleurs le film de
Warda et c'est très surprenant parce que
Godard il tourne aux Champs-Élysées
personne ne sait qui tourne Raoul
Coutard qui est à reporter de guerre est
caché dans une voiture de la poste et
quand Belmondo d'une cyber que descend
des Champs-Élysées personne ne sait qui
fait un film et donc il y a cette
manière de déjouer les codes habituels
et donc il donne une décontraction au
jeu qui est tout à fait surprenante
parce que Belmondo quand il tourne aux
Champs-Élysées ben personne ne sait qui
sait et alors
c'est très intéressant parce que pour un
écrivain par exemple quand vous voyez
comment la mort de Belmondo est tournée
dans la bout de souffle cette sorte de
longue course rue Campagne-Première vous
dites mais tiens comment est-ce que je
vais raconter ça
et donc ce travelling suivi vous dites
tiens quelle est l'équivalent littéraire
de ça donc moi j'essaye de trouver par
exemple le rythme l'inventivité
l'équivalent d'un regard visuel par le
regard littéraire et l'un des plaisirs
d'ailleurs de votre texte votre roman
c'est que vous revenez sur les films
phares les films charnières les films
marquants on les retraverse avec vous et
vous avez le don d'ailleurs de ce qui
n'est pas facile de faire revivre des
films à l'image c'est un peu comme
commenter les matchs de foot à la radio
arriver à faire cet exercice n'est pas
facile et vous le faites brillamment
en dehors de Godard qui va se
radicaliser dans son cinéma on a
l'impression tout de même que passer les
7 8 premières années de la Nouvelle
Vague les cinéastes qu'il a qui la
composent vont progressivement
mais vous savez bon la Nouvelle Vague
moi ce que j'aime c'est son insolence la
liberté le pouvoir d'invention de
modernité de réflexion après ça
évidemment on peut les critiquer très
fort mais moi j'aime le cinéma français
profondément et bien sûr ils ont une
doxa assez sévère assez stricte avec des
infusions j'aime énormément que l'autre
sautais par exemple et de remettre
l'autre côté dans le mouvement Claude au
fond était considéré comme un cinéaste
commercial mais c'est quand même lui qui
a été très proche de Truffaut il était
très amis et donc aujourd'hui que la
Nouvelle Vague est au fond terminé on
peut la rendre de manière plus ouverte
plus joyeux plus pérenne et donc on peut
faire entrer dans la Nouvelle Vague
d'autres cinéastes qui n'en n'ont pas
fait partie et c'est ça que je fais dans
mon livre
c'est qu'au même moment il y a Vadim qui
fait pas partie de la nouvelle vague et
il y a Brigitte Bardot qui est une bombe
oui mais ils en parlent parce qu'il le
défendent en disant bah il casse elle
casse les codes il faut dire que c'était
sous de Gaulle et donc ils vendent de
Gaulle hybrides Bardot c'est pas la même
et d'ailleurs Godard la récupérera dans
le mépris qu'est-ce qu'ici mais il aime
pas il l'a fait brune
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui reste il
reste des films absolument merveilleux
on les revoit d'ailleurs on vous lisant
mais qu'est-ce qui reste parce que ce
mouvement bref fugace a eu un impact
extraordinaire sur l'histoire du cinéma
à l'étranger et en français partout
qu'est-ce qui reste finalement de ça de
de de de l'invention de la nouvelle
vague ou de la rupture de la nouvelle
vague dans le cinéma d'aujourd'hui je
pense un état d'esprit je veux dire
Olivier Assayas par exemple ou
Christophe Honoré sont des cinéastes qui
se réclament de la nouvelle vague qui
ont débuté au cinéma en lisant Les
Cahiers du Cinéma grande influence sur
le cinéma étrangers je crois une
modernité qui a donné un nouveau souffle
au cinéma français il a rajeuni qu'il a
regaillardi au même moment et une
nouvelle vague ailleurs en Angleterre en
République tchèque c'est et les amours
d'une blonde c'est-à-dire en fait c'est
pas un mouvement uniquement français ça
arrive aussi dans d'autres pays même
c'est la naissance du cinéma à New York
et ça c'est une chose à mon avis qui est
importante à rappeler aussi puisque vous
avez la parole vous allez la garder je
suis désolé mais non je vous en prie je
vous en prie alors
c'est écrit des bouquins absolument
formidables et les bouquins notamment
par exemple sur la Belgique que j'ai pu
de lire de lui c'est extraordinaire
donc
roman sur la nouvelle vague et c'est
absolument parfait
à un moment donné vous dites que j'ai
plus quelle est votre formule qu'au fond
vous n'avez pas été très sensible au
cahier du cinéma quand vous étiez jeune
exploitant de salles et c'était pas ses
Cahiers du Cinéma là les Cahiers du
cinéma à l'époque de Truffaut et de et
de Godard j'étais trop jeune pour les
lire et si je les avais lu je saurai
énormément apprécié puisque je les ai
énormément apprécié après c'est ce
d'après c'est à dire quand ils sont
marxisés en quelque sorte et qui sont
devenus incroyablement dogmatiques et
sectaires et ils détestait un cinéma que
moi j'aimais beaucoup qui était le grand
cinéma romanesque américain les films
avec Ava Gardner deboraker ou la nature
neuve qui était les films qui portaient
mon imaginaire d'adolescents et
d'ailleurs vous écrivez un livre sur
Brad Pitt c'est le cinéma qui est
carrément de notre côté c'est le cinéma
des studios et c'est le cinéma des stars
c'est celui qui vous qui vous fait rêver
tout le cinéma me fait rêver en fait
quand j'avais mes salles de cinéma je
passais beaucoup de films de la Nouvelle
Vague le mépris est un film sublime le
générique de étoile étoiles c'était un
plan un plan du mépris j'ai pas j'ai pas
de hier ce que je veux dire simplement
c'est que et cette évolution vient de
dire là qu'ils se sont académisés et
notamment Truffaut quand il a commencé à
défendre des cinéastes qu'il avait
souvent attaqué quand il était critique
finalement le cinéma c'est un corpus où
il y a tout il y a à la fois les
classiques des académiciens et puis
alors les nouveaux qui se coulent
je trouve ça fait partie de la richesse
de la création pourquoi diable vous
intéressez vous à Brad Pitt parce que il
est un bon acteur mais enfin c'est pas
non plus Sean Penn il a pas reçu deux
Oscars certes il est un il est grave
c'est pas grave il a pas non plus la
complexité d'un Johnny Depp qu'est-ce
qui vous a intéressé en lui américain de
cette année pour moi c'est tort qu'il a
reçu aucun Oscar donc c'est pas c'est
pas un critère les Oscars ce qui
m'intéresse avec Brad Pitt c'est qu'il
est à la fois au cœur du système et dans
les marges au cœur du système parce que
il est une star effectivement sur qui on
peut construire des budgets très
importants comme belletred par exemple
et puis dans les marges parce que il
grâce à lui on peut produire terrain de
smalique grâce à lui on peut produire
Frédéric qui vient de de faire le
merveilleux blonde pour Netflix il est
au centre et dans les marges c'est à
dire que dans ce système là il est
totalement libre et c'est ça qui
m'intéresse le plus alors tout commence
pour lui vous le racontez sur votre
premier chapitre dans les 15 minutes de
telmas et Louise où il joue le
personnage de JD d'ailleurs vous dites
que c'est délinquant juvénile moi je
dirais que c'est peut-être les initiales
de JD Salinger peut-être Céline Dion là
lui il le sait pas parce que lui il le
sait pas mais en tous les cas mais en
tous les cas il avait il était là depuis
trois ans déjà Hollywood il avait gravi
petit à petit les échelons et là c'est
en 15 minutes il va exploser pourquoi
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans ces 15
minutes qui vont faire que sa
trajectoire à partir de là va devenir
météorite il y a une raison accessoire
c'est comme Marx qui est hanté
l'inconscient culturel de l'Europe
James Dean hantait l'inconscient
culturel de Hollywood et tout d'un coup
on retrouve gepsin donc c'est une
première chose c'est une première chose
qui va être prisonnier donc il va se
limite il retrouve on retrouve le mythe
type qui apparaît et qui en 15 minutes
débordent tout en plus il est en face
extraordinaire
Davis sont des grandes actrices mais
voilà déjà il y a ça et puis ensuite
qu'est-ce qu'il a de plus et là ce qui
avait Marilyn Monroe ce qui avait James
Dean c'est-à-dire qu'il y a non
seulement un très grand acteur on sent
tout de suite une personnalité qui
échappe au sanalyses alors à côté
il rallume la mémoire et de l'autre il
invente quelque chose de nouveau mais en
même temps qu'on vous dit c'est vrai que
dans son dans telmaël oui il a un côté
James Dean mais ouf quand on regarde
ensuite l'évolution de sa carrière il
est il est pas James Dean il est pas
Elvis Presley c'est pas le c'est un
garçon de bonne famille d'une famille
uni et croyante il a une enfance
heureuse c'est un bon gars de
Springfield il est gentil c'est le
contraire de la déchéance c'est le
contraire du ténébreux quand il tourne
quand il tourne avec son copain
on peut pas dire que ce soit un bon gars
c'est un film absolument terrifiant et
il est ce qui est aussi très touchant
avec lui très intéressant c'est qu'il
est très attaché à sa famille qui sont
dans le Missouri vraiment au bout du
monde qui sont des anabatismes
conservateurs voilà et donc quand il
tourne il a toujours le sentiment qu'il
est en train de les trahir et en même
temps il s'affirme comme étant lui-même
et il arrive à garder un lien avec sa
famille avec son passé c'est à dire
c'est
sa personnalité qui est intéressante sur
cet aspect là il crée quelque chose et
en même temps il vient pas de rien mais
si on faisait des catégories un peu
simpliste il y a des il y a des stars
américaines qui sont des ténébreux il y
a des lumineux lui il est plutôt de la
catégorie lumineux il est le bon
camarade le bon copain mais il a tourné
des films où il est un vrai donc
c'est pas un problème oui mais l'image
qui projette pour les Américains le
point d'identification pour vous c'est
pas plutôt le bon gars auquel on vient
je suis pas sûr je suis pas sûr vous
dites qu'il est dépressif mais c'est pas
très visible qu'il est dépressif non
c'est pas très dépressif sauf qu'il y a
des films quand même quand ils tournent
la mort de Jessie James et son film
préféré et bien il est il est ici il a
pas la part d'ombre la part de
difficulté la part de la part de
révolution presque elle est en lui très
forte sauf que comme je vous le dis il
est il est il maintient tout il
maintient le système parce que ça permet
de précisément d'être libre et puis il
fait ce qu'il veut il a 60 ans
aujourd'hui ou un peu plus il est
toujours aussi beau d'ailleurs c'était
étonnant il est incroyablement beau mais
est-ce que vous on voit bien qu'il va
falloir qu'il change un peu son registre
comment vous imaginez il a il a toujours
je sais que ça pile incroyable mais
comme vous voyez l'avenir pour lui si je
peux me servir me permettre ce que je
lui souhaite c'est une évolution à la
Burt Lancaster c'est à dire qu'en marche
l'encasteur tourne
n'était pas fait pas fait pour faire du
chemin ensemble entre Bart encaster qui
a été tourné dans des western et des
films d'acrobates en slip et de l'autre
côté viscontique était le sommet de la
de la culture
raffinée et décadente c'est-à-dire
aristo comme une ministre italien il y
avait un monde et pourtant ça marchait
très bien et ça complètement
révolutionné la carrière des dix
dernières années de Burt Lancaster moi
ce que je souhaite pour pour Brad Pitt
c'est sur un Tino l'Italie ou un grand
cinéaste français janoly des gens comme
ça qui pourraient lui apporter à partir
d'un texte qui soit pas un texte
hollywoodien qui pourrait lui apporter
ses dimensions là et là ce que je pense
c'est que il y pense lui aussi ce qui
explique pourquoi la raison pour
laquelle il vient si souvent en Europe
et notamment en France c'est que il
cherche quelque chose il voit pas
pouvoir tourner le traîne qui est
pourtant très amusant mais jusqu'à la
fin jusqu'à 70 ans il va pas pouvoir
tourner le Babylone ou d'ailleurs Damien
Chazel fait un film assez étonnant de
brio de mise en scène mais ou en même
temps il arrive pas à comprendre Brad et
il se sert pas bien de devoir être dans
le film la seule la seule scène forte
dans Babylone c'est qu'en Brad Pitt va
avoir la journaliste qu'il a toujours
soutenu et qu'elle lui explique que
c'est terminé c'est sa carrière est
terminée que le train est passé que
c'est foutu il est beaucoup mieux
utilisé dans Once Upon Hollywood
comment vous expliquez Frédéric monsieur
le ministre comment vous expliquer et
d'ailleurs je vais poser la question
aussi à Patrick le cinéma français qui
produit 300 400 films par an à peu près
à générer certes quelques stars Brigitte
Bardot Alain Delon Romy Schneider
mais mais par rapport au cinéma
américain qui est une fabrique à Star
est-ce que c'est parce que chez nous les
acteurs servent les films et que chez
eux les films servent les acteurs
comment vous expliquer qui est un
télécart entre l'incroyable production
de stars du cinéma américain et le fait
que nous nous produisions des acteurs
mais finalement
qui produit sans cesse et qui
m'attendait leurs produits aussi
énormément de séries et de choses comme
ça et entre la machine et l'artisanat
français un artisanat français qui est
très sophistiqué qui fonctionne bien
mais
quand vous voyez qu'être Blanchette dans
Thor vous rendez compte que évidemment
vous demandez quelle est la star
française qui aurait fait un film comme
celui-là et bien non ça n'existe pas
parce qu'un film comme celui-là on peut
pas le faire en France pourquoi ça je ne
sais pas c'est un autre sujet
on va poursuivre cette conversation avec
Cécile une
téléspectatrice qui suit notre émission
et qui veut vous interroger je crois que
c'est vous un bon écoute
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Cécile j'ai 29 ans
je suis une lectrice qui a commencé très
jeune et en fait les écrans sont venus
un peu corrompre cet intérêt pour la
lecture et ces dernières années j'ai
essayé de reconquérir
cet amour de la lecture alors j'ai
choisi de vous parler aujourd'hui d'un
livre que j'ai découvert très récemment
et d'un auteur finalement qui est connu
depuis un certain nombre d'années mais
que j'ai découvert récemment c'est
l'adversaire d'Emmanuel Carrère c'est
une autofiction avec une qui suit les
échanges qui aiment les Carrère avait eu
avec Jean-Claude Romand Jean-Claude
romain en fait c'est un homme qui s'est
tiré dans le mensonge pendant des années
qui a prétendu être un chercheur de
renom un médecin de renom et qui a une
femme des enfants et qui s'est en fait
c'est enfermé dans ce mensonge là au
point où il a dû il a trouvé pour soluce
issu à ce mens que la mise à mort de
toutes sortes de sa famille entière et
en fait c'est j'adore parce que Emmanuel
Carrère explore non seulement l'acte la
raison de l'acte évidemment il y a rien
qui justifie ce qui a été ce qui a été
fait en explorant finalement ce que
Jean-Claude roman a fait il s'explore
lui-même en tant qu'auteur en tant que
personne Frédéric Mitterrand bonjour
alors en fait en lisant votre livre j'ai
eu la sensation que en parlant de Brad
Pitt finalement ce dont vous parliez
c'était une sorte de virilité fantasmée
une idée assez particulière que vous
faites de ce que c'est qu'une
masculinité idéale et la question que je
me pose finalement c'est est-ce que vous
parliez de Brad Pitt l'homme ou est-ce
que parler de Brad Pitt Lidl
Frédéric un des deux Cécile alors là
l'idole ou l'homme c'est à dire la
schizophrénie qui habite un certain
nombre de gens est-ce qu'elle habiterait
aussi Brad Pitt sans doute puisqu'il est
acteur et quand on est acteur c'est un
exercice de schizophrénie on devient on
a une autre identité et le fait qu'il
est une identité tellement forte dans
chacun de ces rôles même lors des films
qui sont pas forcément les meilleurs
mais où il a une présence tellement
extraordinaire c'est justement à une
étude sur sur la schizophrénie et moi je
pense que moi je suis un peu
schizophrène aussi comme beaucoup de
gens c'est les périodes de déprime il y
a des gens que j'aime des gens que
j'aime moins etc mais je n'ai jamais pu
être acteur et je n'ai jamais pu en
faire quelque chose comme ce qu'il en
fait lui
fortune vous prennent l'excuse j'avais
12 ans j'avais 12 ans mais mais je
poursuis une seconde la question de
Cécile
il est il est complètement il est sans
ambiguïté je trouve sexuel Brad Pitt il
est né c'est une figure très très hétéro
de de de de de de de l'acteur et c'est
lui que vous avez choisi vous avez
choisi un acteur sans ambiguïté
de vous moi je suis hété refrain de
livre c'est pas un problème
d'archange je dirais il y a une grosse
projection de vous-même ça c'est très
juste de divination de pas de divination
mais de sur lui il y a il y a en lui il
y a quelque chose qui
quelque chose de moral que je cherche
oui mais pas la morale emmerdante
comment rester libre dans un système
tellement normé que le système du cinéma
hollywoodien et ça ça me fascine il est
beaucoup plus libre que Tom Cruise avec
ses talonnette et son
marin de sous-marin
c'est pour ça je souhaite de vivre
encore longtemps l'émission est
quasiment fini il nous reste simplement
à partager avec ceux qui nous ont suivi
notre goût de lecture du moment nous
coups de cœur donc je vais vous demander
à chacun d'entre vous de dire quel est
le livre que vous leur recommandez mais
attention c'est satisfait remboursé il
faut qu'il soit vraiment très heureux du
choix que vous leur proposez Frédéric
parce qu'il vient juste de sortir c'est
un chinois qui s'appelle Tao
chez Fayard et le titre s'appelle
étranger sur la grève et c'est
l'histoire des Chinois qui vivent en
Malaisie chassés par la misère c'est
extraordinairement raconté dans un style
totalement original
Patrick Fayard le chemin continue chez
Gallimard une biographie de Georges
Lambrix par Arnaud Vilanova alors
Georges Lambrix était éditeur aux
éditions
il était éditeur de Beckett de Claude
Simon puis après ça il s'entendait pas à
des propriétés il est passé chez Grasset
rapidement
il a créé la collection le chemin il
était le premier à publier l'occasion il
avait deux principes il avait pas de
comité de rédaction et il disait aux
auteurs
deux choses ou bien ça ne va pas quand
ça n'allait pas ou bien c'était pas tant
alors à la rédaction de au bonheur des
livres on a choisi le livre d'Hélène
frappa Frédéric Mitterrand je crois que
vous avez débattu avec elle trois hommes
disent trois femmes disparaissent pardon
c'est sur une lignée de d'actrice
ipodent sa fille mélanie Griffith et
cela fille de sa fille Dakota Johnson
c'est beaucoup agacé pendant notre débat
parce que j'ai dit elle est belle et
blonde je lui ai dit qu'elle aurait
beaucoup plus à elle elle a réagit
aimablement mais en tout cas le livre
est très fin très intéressant sur le la
malédiction sur le cinéma et sa
malédiction qui poursuit une famille
François Truffaut et Hélène Scott ça
c'est la correspondance
qui avait déjà raconté l'histoire de de
ce couple amical et là il publie leur
correspondance c'est tout à fait
passionnant vous l'avez vous l'avez vu
oui oui bien sûr je l'offre à Frédéric
un vrai écrivain ah bah oui d'ailleurs
c'est un point commun de vous de la
nouvelle vague c'est que la plupart
d'entre eux remèrent
Truffaut ils sont des écrivains ou des
libraires ou des éditeurs qui des
philosophes et on lit aussi beaucoup
dans leur livre Scott était absolument
merveilleux c'était une grosse dame
d'une intelligence lumineuse et d'une
sympathique fantastique Truffaut n'est
pas toujours gentil Jean-Michel Parker
c'est un dictionnaire des actrices
françaises préfacées par Besnard on
connaissait le Parker du vin c'est un
autre par coeur là c'est le Parker des
actrices ça va vous amuser je suis sûr
c'est pour vous non mais attendez il
faut donner un livre
donné vous inquiétez pas et enfin
les mémoires d'Alain Delon est rédigé
par Denitsa bencheva et Liliana rosca
avec une préface de lui et des photos
enfin bon voilà c'est son son propre
récit de lui-même
la vérité c'est un homme extrêmement
attaché
il a malgré ses déclarations quelques
fois tonitruantes
profondément attaché il ressemble aux
personnages d'acteurs que vous aimez une
raison très simple aussi c'est qu'il a
le culte de l'amitié et ça c'est une
chose qui est très belle les amis c'est
pas des gens avec qui ont des forcément
d'accord mais c'est des gens auprès de
qui on doit rester fidèles voilà cette
émission est terminée je vous remercie
l'un et l'autre je remercie Cécile je
recommande la lecture de vos ouvrages si
vous voulez revoir cette émission vous
pouvez le faire sur le site de Public
Sénat et sinon nous nous retrouvons la
semaine prochaine à la même heure à
moins que d'ici là nous ne nous soyons
croisés dans une librairie merci et
bonsoir merci à vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous a présenté
au bonheur des livres